الناطق باسم قياده الجيش الاوكراني سركي
شيريغاتي ان الجيش استعاد سيطره بشكل كامل
على مدينه باخموت نحاول ان نفهم مزيد من
التفاصيل مع مراسيل عمر الحاجه ينضم لنا
الان من كرامه تورس اهلا بك معنا.
نعم عبد السلام وليد فقط ان ابدا بهذا
المكان الذي قصف قبل اقل من ساعه من الان
وسط مدينه اكرامتوس في عمليات همم وصفاتها
السلطات المحليه بانها جزء من عمليات
ريتال العمليات الانتقاميه لما يحدث في
باخم في التصريحات التي ادلى بها المتحدث
باسم الجبهه الشرقيه بشكل خاصيه الجزيره
اكد فيه مره اخرى ان القوات الاوكرانيات
تمكنت من استعاده السيطره بشكل كامل على
كامل احياء مدينه
باخم شرقيه دنيا اسكو انها تمكنت من طرد
القوات الروسيه خارج الحدود الاداريه لهذه
المدينه اضافه الى انها تمكنت من تامين
المنطقه الصناعيه التي كانت منطلقا
للعمليات العسكريه
لمجموعات التي تقوده الهجومه هناك اضافه
الى قوات الجيش الروسي ولكنه عاده للتاكيد
مره اخرى بان المدينه تتعرض بشكل كبير
لقصف عنيف من راجمات الصواريخ ثقيله اضافه
الى مدفعيه
من عيار 152 تحدثت عنها هيئه الاركان في
وقت سابق وان هذه الاسلحه تفوق مدافع
الميدان بالتحديد تفوق وما لدى الجيش
الاوكراني من اسلحه اضاف الى اضافه الى
ذلك تحدث عن الجبهه الشماليه تحديدا محور
ستوفوفا وكريمينا وقال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحقق تقدما وان كان بطيئا في
تلك المنطقه وان ما يعقوب تقدم الجيش
الاوكراني والسيطره على هاتين المدينه هو
انتشار الالغاء التي زرعتها القوات
الانفصاليه والجيش الروسي على مدى الاشهر
الماضيه في همم ايضا في القصف على المدن
والبلدات همم في همم مقاطعه اندونيس قبل
قليل افادت همم مصادر همم رسميه هنا بتعرض
لمدينه كره اضافه الى مدينه تشيلسي الى
قصف من قبل القوات الروسيه ادى الى وقوع
ضحايا في صفوف المدنيين اخيرا في مقاطعه
قوات الاوكرانيه دفعت بتعزتنا عسكريه الى
تلك المنطقه ما يثار هنا وصلت اوكرانيا ان
الوجه القادم هي توك ماك اضافه الى مدينه
ميلوتوث ذات الاهميه الاستراتيجيه والتي
سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه مع بدايه
الحرب اضافه الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
والمصادر الرسميه الاوكرانيه نشرت صورا عن
تعزاتنا عسكريه الروسيه سيقت من مدينه
ماريو بول وايضا من برنسك في مقاطعه
لتقويه الخطوط الدفاعيه الروسيه في تلك
المدينه
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الاضاحات